este problema dicen evalúa 3x cuadrada
menos 8 x 7 en x igual a menos 2 o sea
básicamente tenemos que cambiar todas
las x de aquí por menos 2 vamos a ver
qué nos queda nos quedaría 3 por aquí en
vez de x va a menos 2 - 2 al cuadrado
menos 8 x en vez de esta xv aún menos 2
+ 7 muy bien vamos a hacer las
operaciones aquí menos 2 al cuadrado es
4 porque menos por menos es más y dos
por dos es cuatro entonces nos queda
tres por cuatro menos ocho por menos 12
16 entonces lo voy a poner así menos 16
y luego tengo que sumar 7 más 7 muy bien
vamos a ver qué nos queda este 3 por 4
es un 12 lo voy a poner aquí 12 aquí
tenemos que restar menos 16 entonces es
lo mismo que sumar 16 sumar 16 y
finalmente hay que sumar ese 7 vamos a
ver cuánto nos da 12 con 16 es 28 y 28
más 7 es 30
entonces la respuesta es 35